Before I write any code, I'm going to figure out all of the dimensions and
specifications of my rectangles. Box will match the specifications given. So,
it'll be at 60, 90 and have a width of 20 and a height of 30. The question asks
for the dimensions of both boxes to be the same. So this one will also be 20
wide and 30 tall. I need to figure out where this upper left corner is. It
looks like it's 20 to the right from 60, so that should be at 80. And it's also
30 down from 90, so that should 120. Now, I have all of the specifications, and
I need to put them into the constructor calls. So, in the BlueJ project, I'll
edit the code for rectangle demo. Open editor. And then the main method, I'm
going to create two rectangles: Box and Box Two. And then once I've created
them, I'm going to draw them. We'll make box a new rectangle. Now, this
constructor needs to take an x, a y, a width and a height. X we know is 60, y
is 90, the width is 20 and the height is 30. Now for box two, x is 80, y is
120, the width is 20 and the height is 30. So if I stretch this out, it should
look like this. Let's compile, and now I'll run my method. And it drew my
rectangles, just as I asked for.